so as I was driving home from this movie
I was thinking how did this movie come
about it was probably a conversation
something like this you got a movie and
you gotta make movie it's go before well
me and you will be a lot of fun oh yeah
those are my tools yells same visible
they won't steal I'm paraphrasing of
course escape plan starring Sylvester
Stallone and Arnold Schwarzenegger
that's really all I need to know and I
am there now Stallone in this movie
plays a character who for a living
breaks out of Prisons he is hired to go
to various prisons pretend to be a
normal inmate he has maybe like one
person in the entire prison who knows
what's going on to be able to find the
structural weaknesses of this facility
and when he's hired to go into this
prison that's this humongously secret
prison where the warden is Jim Caviezel
he meets Arnold Schwarzenegger there and
they decide to team up once they realize
there's a bit of a setup going on here
and not everything is how it seems now I
am a big fan of these guys really I mean
I grew up watching Stallone movies I
grew up watching sports and Egger movies
and just seeing these guys on-screen is
entertaining in itself just seeing these
guys sit down and have a conversation in
a movie that's fun for me and this seems
like a really good idea you know
Stallone and sports nigga trying to
break out of a prison because I like
Prison Break movies historically they're
pretty fun movies generally if they're
done well I mean Clint Eastwood in
Escape from Alcatraz we're gonna say
Krosh Hank Redemption the greatest
Prison Break movie ever and that's
really what this movie is a lot of fun
the planning and the actual execution of
the eventual escape because everything
leading up to that it was like a movie
that steadily got a little bit better
because it started out very mediocre ly
like the first 20 minutes of this movie
I was like oh boy this should be a lot
better than it is but honestly as soon
as Stallone met Swartz nigger in the
movie and these two actors got to bounce
off each other and their charisma
exploded it was like okay this movie is
a lot of fun and from then on I really
enjoy escape plan surprisingly it
actually has a lot of pretty cool
elements to it and it's not just that I
enjoy watching Schwarzenegger with a big
gun in slow motion and
Stallone kickin ass all over the place
that is awesome if it's done well and if
there's a story behind it you can
actually care about and in this movie
there is there are certain things about
it where like okay I actually want to
see this happen I want to see this work
out and for that reason I was more into
the movie than I would have been if it
was just hey you wanna break out of the
prison you go in there and we'll get the
pins I'll stick it in the door and you
take your dagger you put it you think
I'll do it I'll do it honestly I'd pay
to see that too but there was actually a
story behind the movie that I was
invested in which is pretty cool another
thing I really liked about this movie
was actually Jim Caviezel as the warden
essentially the main villain of the
movie and I thought he did a really good
job as the villain he was very cold you
know you couldn't really see any emotion
in his eyes he didn't care at all about
these people that's the kind of guy you
would need to run a facility this brutal
and Jim Caviezel really pulled it off in
this movie I thought he really added
something good to this movie but the
film never got to the point where it
took itself too seriously and that's
something I enjoyed too because with a
film like this it's very much so a
Friday night midnight type movie where
you get some pizza some popcorn some
soda or whatever and you pop in a skate
plan and you have some fun with it and
the movie understood that because it had
the slow-motion moments you know it had
the big one-liners there were elements
to the movie that could have been a lot
better there was a certain part to the
film whenever it cut away from the
prison I was almost always bored you
know there were certain scenes worth
characters outside of the facility that
bored me I wish that it kind of just
always stayed in the prison I think
that's where the film faltered a lot it
would cut away from the prison and go to
these other characters who are doing
things outside and I was like I don't
care about this at all just get away
from these characters they're pointless
characters I understand why they're
there but they're not interesting
remotely and I think that the film
always lost something whenever I'd cut
away from the facility also there was
one moment in the movie towards the end
where I was actually truly getting into
the film I was really really into it and
they just threw this really cheesy line
in there and I was like not necessary at
all I'm not gonna spoil it for you but
it just kind of drained the moment for
me unfortunately but escape plan kind of
caught me off guard actually I was very
surprised by how much fun I have with
this movie the charisma of Stallone and
swartz nigga really helped and Jim
Caviezel was really good in the movie as
well I'm gonna give it a B I mean this
movie just feels like it came out at
night
97 which is really cool to me guys
thanks very much for watching and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes